انا الان همم من نيودلهي للسدواء العواده
الكاتبه صحفيه المختص في الشؤون الاسيويه
اسدواء اهلا وسهلا بك على 24 نتوقف معك
عند هذه الزياره للرئيس الصيني الى
السعوديه صفحه جديده اذا تفتح من جديد في
هذه العلاقات بين بكين والرياض من جهه لكن
ايضا بين بكين والعالم العربي من خلال
هاتين القدامتين قمه خارجيه همم صينيه
واخرى عربيه صينيه ما الذي تسعى اليه
السعوديه من خلال توجيه هذه الدعوه لشجن
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بالف خير لا شك بان
العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه ليست علاقات في
مبدا الطاقه الى
الصين من قبل السعوديه التي تعد المصادر
الرئيسي للنفط الى
الصين لكن هناك دلالات اخرى على مدى
التعاون بين البلدين وخاصه بين بين دول
الخليج العربي ايضا وبين مع الصين في
مبادره حزام واحد طريق واحد للرئيس
بالاضافه الى التعاون في الصناعات
العسكريه وتوفير الاستقرار الامني والسلام
في هذه المنطقه لانها من مصلحه الصين
والدول الخليج ان يكون هناك استقرار في
هذه المنطقه لذلك اعتقد ان هناك تغيرا
جذريا في السياسه الاستراتيجيه الصينيه
تجاه هذه المنطقه من ناحيه وكذلك الامر من
وجهه النظر العربيه التي تقول التوجه شرقا
باعتبار انها تريد ان تنوع من سنه العملات
التي تحاولها لاستفاده منها ان كانت توصيل
او روسيا او غيرها حتى ايضا لذلك علاقات
الاستفاده ربحا لكل الطرق
اللي هذه هي الزياره ربما ستعكس شداء
التقارب بين بكين والسعوديه بكين والرياض
في عديد من المجالات اقتصاديه دفاعيه
امنيه همم الى ما ذلك من القطاعات
والمجلات ايضا ثقافيه لكن اي تداعيات لهذا
التقارب الصينيه السعودي همم على موقف
واشنطن
جذريه في العلاقات الامريكيه السعوديه
خاصه في ظل الرئيس الذي يحاول ان يبتعد
كثيرا عن ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان لكن في
حقيقه الامر ان السعوديه تدرك انها
والوجود العسكري الامريكي في المنطقه
يعتبر الرئيسي باملها واستقرارها لكنها
تريد ان تنوع من مصادر عسكريه بالنسبه لها
وتريد ان ترسل رسائل ضمنيه الى الولايات
المتحده بانها قادره على تتخذ سياسه
الاستراتيجيه شبه مستقله والبعض ايضا ينظر
الى ان هذا التقارب ايضا ربما يكون
بالتوجه من قبل الولايات المتحده الى
السعوديه لتعزيز علاقتها مع الصين لتخفيف
الاعتماد الصيني على ايران وبالتالي هي
اوراق مختلفه بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
لكن بشتى الاحوال الولايات المتحده تدرك
ان التقارب السعودي مع الصين هي رساله
واضحه للولايات المتحده التي تحاول ان تضع
السعوديه تحت قانون الجثه واتهامها
بالوقوف وراء الاحداث الحادي عشر سبتمبر
كل ذلك يدل على ان التازن في العلاقات
الامريكيه للصينيه القادمه
وصفت برنامج هذه الزياره سجن بينك
الرياض بانه يمثل اكبر نشاط دي بروماسي
بين الصين والعالم العربي منذ تاسيس
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه الى اي مدى يمكن
همم ان ربما تشكل هذه الزياره همم اختلافا
في التوازن الحالي في العلاقات الجنسيه او
ربما بوادر نظام عالم جديد
ربما يكون بوادر نظام عالم جديد اكثر
واقعيه لان العالم العربي للاسف ارتبط
بشكل جذري مع القوات الاستعماريه الغربيه
الامريكيه التي احتلت هذه المنطقه على مدى
العقود الماضيه ولكنها ابتعدت بشكل كبير
عن الثقافه الشرقيه الهنديه والصينيه
وبالتالي العوده الى الجذور دليل على ان
الدول العربيه ربما بدات تصل الى مرحله
الوعي الذاتي والواقعيه في التعامل بعيدا
عن سياسه المفاضله والاستفاده الاخر من
هذه السياسات على مصالحها الخاصه
لا الشكر لك يا استاذ وائل عواد الكاتب
الصحفي المختص في الشؤون الاسيوي حدثنا
منيو دله شكرا جزيلا لك